hi I'm Joanna Smith and today we'll look
at how streaming analytics from Google
cloud helps bring the real-time
ecommerce experience to life real time
data is unique and that it provides an
opportunity for businesses to react
without delay valuable events such as an
online shopper clicking on items details
can trigger dynamic and immediate
experiences on a website or mobile app
the opportunity to generate value around
this data type is only growing in fact
the International Data Corporation
estimates that within five years more
than a quarter of all data globally will
be real-time in nature but for an
application to react to real-time data
it's crucial to have data analysis
insights and actions that occur without
human intervention stream analytics does
just that
offering automated real-time data
analysis let's take a look here we've
got our e-commerce site new kicks and on
the right throughout this demo you'll
see some context on what's happening
behind the JavaScript on the GCP
platform let's take a look at how stream
analytics can improve the new kicks
shopping experience and drive sales
we've used pub/sub data flow bigquery
and BigTable to create the data streams
that will allow new kicks to make their
data actionable within milliseconds of
being generated for example the hot item
flag is created in real time as pub/sub
ingest user clicks throughout the site
to be processed by data flow allowing
new kicks to determine which products
are currently being viewed by at least
50 people when our shopper clicks on
item they see that there are 62 people
looking at these exact shoes at this
moment our shopper as the shoes to their
cart and immediately sees a low
inventory alert powered by data from the
inventory stream and based on real-time
stock availability information to
reliably offer this type of shopping
experience even during busy times new
fix relies on pub subs ability to ingest
millions of events per second combined
with data flows exactly once processing
with fault tolerance if a user misses
their opportunity window and the shoes
become out of stock real-time AI can
turn a frustrating user moment into a
seamless exchange with a personalized
product replacement suggestion in
parallel this inventory insight also
enables new ticks to trigger a back-end
stock replenish process our shopper
liked the alternative shoes and when
checking out is offered a chance to pick
them up in a nearby
store here new tix uses real-time
inventory and transactional data from
the local stores to offer the user a
chance to get their shoes faster
real-time data enabled new kicks to act
and react to create a positive purchase
experience that's one more happy
customer now let's take a look at how
this works within the Google cloud
platform real time data is generated
based on certain events like user
interactions so the first step is to
configure an event to push to pub/sub
which will serve as a trigger for a
particular data stream to create that
data stream start by defining a topic in
putzi with stackdriver we can see
high-level summaries for our pub sub
activity here we have the rate of
incoming messages for all three of new
pixs data streams the message volume
comes in bursts based on the day of the
week or the time of day our demo peaks
at around two to three hundred messages
per second but could scale the thousands
or even millions of events per second
without anyone having to change a thing
no planning necessary because pub/sub is
a fully managed service that
automatically scales to what's needed
another interesting summary is the
oldest unacknowledged message within any
topic here we can see they are being
picked up just a few seconds after being
pushed into pub sim and with this
monitoring system we can set up alerts
to send out notifications if values
extend beyond Rs ellos after the data is
ingested it needs to be processed and
this is where data flow takes over by
establishing data flow pipelines those
initial events can trigger application
behaviors business logic or even
additional processing steps these
pipelines run on the flexible open
source Apache beam SDK they were built
programmatically using data flows wide
variety of supported programming
languages including Java Python and the
recent edition of sequel with more set
to come in stackdriver we can see graphs
of the rate of processing for data flow
but let's take a deeper look at how we
actually process that data in the data
flow monitoring graph we can explore
each of the three streaming pipelines we
saw four new kicks click inventory and
transactional on this page we see
various statistics for the pipeline CPU
throughput etc but for a closer look
over the pipeline is actually doing
let's change tabs
now we can see the processing pipeline
there are three sources of data each
being processed independently before
joining together for cross stream
analytics from data validation and
correction to flattening and formatting
all of this is happening in real time
rather than through a series of batch
processing steps interestingly some
pipelines pull data from a pub sub sink
and land right back in pubs up for the
next stage of processing this is one of
the core promises of stream analytics
joining the data analytics processing
system directly to the operational
systems once processed our data moves
side there BigTable for low latency high
concurrency availability back to the new
kicks website order bigquery for deeper
analytics we saw how the new pic
supplied these data streams within their
website so now let's take a look at what
happens in bigquery in the bigquery user
interface the datasets this user can
access are listed on the left and we can
choose to look at the click stream table
under the retail data set we can see it
has about a hundred and eighteen million
rows of data and that it is Auto
partitioned by time using the timestamp
column
additionally right here within the
bigquery web UI users have the ability
to write and run sequel queries against
both data flow for further ease and
flexibility of pipeline creation and
bigquery we've already seen data flow in
action so let's run a query against the
fresh data in bigquery say the last 10
minutes we can also run more complex
queries like this one which merges our
click stream and transactional data
streams to output popular sales items
sold online in the last 10 minutes
versus in store in the last hour
the power of stream analytics is that
the entire process from the first event
trigger to your application reacting is
entirely hands-off once you set up your
data stream the auto scaling
capabilities of pubs up and data flow
help ensure that the entire interaction
keeps working even at the busiest
moments but when you do want to take a
deeper look dashboards for real-time
data and data streams are still classic
let's take that closer look in looker we
can see visualizations for data analysts
supporting real time website activity
for example here we have our purchase
conversion funnel this data is updating
with an auto refresh running every
minute even though stream analytics
occur in real time dashboards like this
allow you to review performance in order
to glean insights and optimize for the
future looker consumes and aggregates
real time data streams to help new kicks
determine themes like we're in the
purchasing process a user is most likely
to abandon or weather hot item Flags
perform best when set to display for
products with greater than 50 viewers or
greater than 100 viewers and that is how
stream analytics from Google cloud built
on the auto scaling infrastructure of
pub/sub data flow and bigquery helps
bring to life the real-time ecommerce
experience check the documentation to
learn more and thanks for watching
[Music]